>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
>> Joe Yonan: I'm happy
today to introduce one
of my favorite food writers,
Adam Gopnik although, you know,
I have to confess that only we food
focused people refer to him only
as a food writer because he has
written about so many subjects.
It just so happens that I
guess I'm not nearly as much
of a Renaissance man as he or maybe
I just have a shorter attention span
because I find myself quite happily
occupied solely by his food writing.
And since we are here in the
food room that's what I'm going
to focus on here.
Adam has been writing for
the New Yorker since 1986
and he's perhaps best known for
his work concentrating on France
where he lived for
many years and about
which he has written
extensively most recently
in the book The Table
Comes First, Family,
France and the Meaning of Food.
Adam thinks deeply about
food I think it's safe to say
and even better for his readers he
expresses his thoughts about food
with a rare combination of wit,
sensitivity, emotion and logic.
Here are a few lines from
The Table Comes First
that might give you an idea
if you don't have one already
about the way Adam thinks
and writes about food.
We shouldn't intellectualize
food he writes
because that makes it too remote
from our sensory pleasures,
but we ought to talk as
intelligently as we can about it
because otherwise it makes our
sensory pleasures too remote
from our minds.
The knowledge that
our senses are part
of our intelligence is
what makes us human.
We alone know our fun.
The sweetness in our
morning coffee is
at once a feeling,
an idea and a memory.
Ladies and gentlemen, please
welcome to the stage Adam Gopnik.
[ Applause ]
>> Adam Gopnik: Thank you, Joe.
What a nice intro.
Thank you.
What a nice introduction.
Thank you so much for that.
I thought I would start off our
conversation by telling you a story
about food if I might,
about how food changes
in a marriage, how food affects you.
One of the fascinating
things about food is
that we have this natural
capacity to make every mouth taste
that we experience
into a moral taste.
Whatever we're eating we don't
just eat and enjoy or eat and treat
with disgust even we
immediately make it
into some kind of moral principle.
God reasons this way, right?
God once had bacon and he said I
hate that so nobody is ever going
to eat that who is one
of my chosen people.
We moralize about food as
naturally as we ingest it.
And one of the ways you see that,
one of the places where you see
that I've always thought most
clearly is in long marriages.
Marriages.
Every good marriage has an
argument in it about food.
Have you ever, you surely
have noticed this, right?
And it's always the same
argument over and over again.
I had my Uncle Ron and
my Aunt Rose who lived
like all elderly Jewish
people in Florida.
It's a law they were sent
there at a certain point.
Always had the same argument
for as long as I knew them
and the argument was that
my Uncle Ron would say
that they charge you
more in restaurants,
they give you large portions
in restaurants in order
to charge you more and my Aunt
Rose would always say they have
to charge you more in restaurants
because they give you
such large portions.
And they carried on this
argument for at least 60 years
that I was aware of and are probably
still arguing about it in heaven
and even tragically after Uncle Ron
lost his vocal chords he would just
say it in a high voice.
They charge you, they give you
big portions because they want
to charge you more, Rose.
And she would come back at him.
Every, every marriage like my
parents are devoted to food.
My mother, some of you may have read
I wrote a piece about cooking bread
with my mother a couple
of years ago.
It's not in the book, it's
not in The Table Comes First,
but I'll put it in some
other book someday.
And that was where we sort
of discovered each other
was in the kitchen.
My mother taught me how
to cook when I was a boy.
I had 5 sisters if you can imagine,
and but she it was more important
for the boys in the family to
learn to cook than the girls.
So I learned to cook with my mother
and she's a fantastic cook, but she
and my father have had the
same quarrel for as long
as I can remember and that is
about how many desserts
she is serving him.
They have just celebrated their
60th wedding anniversary too
and they are still
having the same quarrel.
He says, Myrna, please don't give
me 3 desserts tonight and she does
and then they just go right back
into the same thing the next night.
I've been married for a little
while and my wife, Martha,
and I have always had
the same argument,
but our argument doesn't turn
around why they charge your more
in restaurants or about questions
of being given an over
abundance of food.
Our argument is always about
one subject and it's about,
some of you I'm sure have
had this argument too it's
about rare and well-done meat.
I come from a rare family
and my wife, Martha,
who is of Icelandic descent, comes
from a very well-done family.
[Laughter] And when you're
first courting someone,
when you're first going out
with them and you're first going
to restaurants with them
and you don't quite
believe what you're hearing.
You don't.
When somebody says well-done on a
first date, you assume it's a joke.
[Laughter] You assume
it's an affectation
that someone is putting on.
Beautiful girl and she's saying she
wants something well-done you just
assume she doesn't really mean that.
She's just saying that because
she thinks it's compelling,
it's winning.
And then you go and you meet
her family and you discover
that there are entire families,
clans, races of the well-done.
And it's totally shocking to you.
And I would go for a cookout in
her, at her family's little house
in the suburbs of Montreal
where I grew up, met her,
and her father would have
a hamburger on the grill
and he would leave it there and
leave it there and leave it there
and days were going by and
nobody would remove this
and that's the way they liked
it because that mouth taste
for well-done was a moral
taste in that family.
It showed your distance
from your peasant roots
and showed your distance
from the farm.
They all came from families
of Icelandic farmers
and that showed how far you'd come
from actually knowing the animal
on a first-name basis because
it had been totally transformed
into a bloodless object
at the end of it.
My family on the other hand
was a very rare family exactly
because for them it was a form
of rejecting the taste
of their parents, right?
Because they, I come from
a Jewish family obviously
and their parents liked highly
koshered overcooked meat.
When my great grandmother
would have you over for dinner,
she would really have
you over for dinner.
You would sit in the kitchen
and she would put food
on your plate and then
leave the room.
It was always hugely well-done.
So my parents took on
the manner of the rare.
They liked anything that was bloody.
It was a sign of their
assimilation into Europe,
their osmosis into France,
their having an entirely new set
of Bohemian and transgressive
values that included the power
and the imagery of spurting
blood from your dinner.
So this was a very deep quarrel,
very deep difference that Martha
and I took through life and you know
as it is when you have those kinds
of tastes, you don't begin by
crediting that they're serious
and then you're always sure that
the other person can reform.
You're always sure that the
other person will change,
and I was always sure
that if only I was cooking
for her she would get better.
And we got married and moved
to New York and I discovered
that she was never
going to get better.
She always liked things well-done.
So then we had children and it
carried on, and we became a kind
of family rift in as much as she
enlisted the children on her side
of this divide, and I realized,
of course, after a certain time
as I'm sure all of you have
realized since I raised the subject
that essentially what's
involved in questions of rare
and well-done is sexual rejection.
[Laughter] That's obviously
what underlies it.
One offers your wife something that
is pink and bloody and engorged
and she says no and the
content couldn't be clearer,
the moral content of that choice.
But one day not too long ago I was,
it was actually a while ago now
that I think about it because
the kids small, I was doing tuna.
I was doing tuna au Poivre,
you know, where you do tuna
in the same way the French do steak
au Poivre, it's a delicious thing,
and of course, as all of you
in this hall will agree tuna
can only be served rare.
[Laughter] Tuna that is not served
rare is not tuna it is tuna fish.
[Laughter] And you recall tuna fish
a totally different gustatory world
than tuna, right?
It comes in a can and you
slice it on a diagonal,
on toast with mayonnaise.
Tuna has got to be cooked rare
so I did my tuna au Poivre
and I served it rare and my wife
cut into it and I could see the look
of dismay on her face and I could
see our beautiful children mirroring
the look of dismay on her face,
and it cut me to the quick.
It involved sexual rejection,
familial sides taking,
a belief somehow that my
understanding of everything
that tuna should be was inadequate
to the measure of their appetites.
It was a disaster.
And I did what I have never done
in my 30 years of married life,
I actually got up from the
table and like a husband
in an old 1960s era television
show I made for the door.
Grabbed my coat and
made for the door.
And my wife, Martha,
intercepted me at the door
and we all know those moments
even though you know you're going
to be coming back we all know
that there are certain trusts,
certain bonds that
when you break you know
that they never ever are going
to be remended completely,
never going to be completely
rewoven, and we were at one
of those moments and Martha
intercepted me at the door
and she said you are coming
back and you are going
to finish cooking that fish.
[Laughter]
And I did.
I knew that I had to.
I knew that the ultimate
moral taste that was at stake
with that mouth taste was the
continuation of our family.
And I went back and I put the tuna
back on the, in the cast iron pan
and I finished cooking it.
But in any marriage that works well
at all there's a natural
give and take.
Martha had won that
confrontation and rightly so,
but I began to notice in the weeks
and months that followed that moment
at the doorway that Martha eased
her way into a new vocabulary
and it was rooted in a single
beautiful word, medium.
[Laughter] Medium.
She began to say in
restaurants now I swear medium
and the beautiful thing about
medium is that it shades
over beautifully either into rare
or into well-done and
no one can complain.
You can say medium
well or medium rare
and you don't really get the moral
indignation of the other side
of the table because the
official declaration is medium
and the secondary declaration
doesn't really matter as much.
She moved all the way to
medium just to placate me.
And I began doing something else
as the cook of the family instead
of continuing to saute because I
saw that that's where the crisis was
in our marriage it was in the
act of frying and sauteing
which presents you irrevocably with
the challenge of rare and well-done,
I began to braise everything.
[Laughter] I began to braise and
stew the family dinner over and over
because when you're
braising and stewing,
rare and well-done never
come to mind as categories.
Instead you're presented with a
simpler category tough or tender.
[Laughter] And if rare and
well-done are the moral symbols
of those first years of marriage,
the bloody and it's rejection,
tough and tender are inevitably the
moral resting places of marriages
in their third and fourth
decades as they go on.
All you want is for
things between you
to be tender as they
can possibly be.
And so between those two simple
linguistic declarations medium
and braised to a tender touch
our marriage has survived
and what I think I've learned
from that process and from
that transaction is that my
Uncle Ron and my Aunt Ruth were
onto something, my Aunt Rose,
were onto something that was real.
And that is that in a decent,
long surviving marriage the portions
always get bigger but you don't have
to pay as much as you used to.
So, thank you very much.
That's a story about food.
[ Applause ]
That's a story about
food and now let me,
I want to have a conversation with
you but let me read you a couple
of things from this book of mine,
which I haven't looked
at in a while.
I had been writing about food as
Joe was saying for the New Yorker
for a long time, but it was
sort of a sporadic enterprise.
I would write, you know, we
do a food issue every year,
and I was always enlisted
to write something.
And I lived in France and
people assume that if you live
in France you must be sort of a
gastronome rather you actually are
or not, you know, if
they post you to Madrid,
I don't think they expect you to
fight bulls, but if they post you
to Paris, they expect you
to know a lot about food.
And so I had all of these pieces
and my publisher said you should
put these all together in a book
and that would be a
good thing to do,
but I don't like to
just put pieces together
in a book unless I can moralize it,
unless I can aerate and amplify it
with some thematic unity
beyond the subject matter.
So I was struggling to do it.
I was struggling to do that.
I was thinking what's
this really about?
What's this book really
going to be about?
And I stumbled on one of the most
astonishing letters I've ever read,
and when I read that
letter I knew that that's
where I would begin the book.
So let me read it to you if I may.
In the early, this begins the book,
in the early morning 6:40 precisely,
of May 24, 1942, a young
professor of German resistant
who had taken the underground
name of Jacques Decour,
his real name was Daniel
Decourdemanche,
and had taught before the war
at the Lycee Carnot in Paris,
which is a fancy school,
wrote a letter to his parents.
You know that for the past two
months, Jacques Decour wrote,
I have been expecting what is
to happen to me this morning.
So I have had the time
to prepare myself for it,
but since I have no religion
I have not given myself
up to any meditation on death.
Here are a few requests.
I was able to send a
word to the woman I love.
If you see her, soon I hope,
give her your affection.
This is my dearest wish.
I also wish that you
could keep an eye
on her parents that need help badly.
Give them the things that are
in my apartment and which belong
to their daughter; the volume
of the Pliad [phonetic],
the Fables of Lafontaine
and the menu
of the inn [Speaking French]
the 5 pagan stones of the king.
All these last days I have
thought a lot about the good meals
that we should have
together when I was free.
You will eat them without
me all the family together,
but not sadly, please.
I don't want your thoughts
to dwell on the food times
that we might have had but on
those that we really have shared.
During those two months of
solitude without even anything
to read I have run over in my mind
all my travels, all my experiences,
all the meals that I have eaten,
I even composed the
outline of a novel.
I had an excellent meal with
Sylvan [phonetic] on the 17th.
I often think of it
with pleasure as well
as of the New Year supper we
shared with Pierre and Renee.
Questions of food you see have
taken on for me a great importance.
And three hours later
what was going to happen
to Decour what he references
happened to him he was shot
by the Nazis in the
courtyard of the prison.
There he was in the last
hours of his life thinking
about sending a menu from a
little inn near Versailles
to his girlfriend's parents,
they must have eaten there once.
His last thoughts turned
to his best loved meals.
Of course he's nobly trying to
ease the horror for his parents,
but he's also trying to
find something to hang onto.
Questions of food, he says, you see
have taken on a great importance.
And when I stumbled on that letter
by Jacques Decour in a collection
of letters written
by French resistors,
I knew that I had found my
subject, which was really deeper
or in a way more far reaching
than just why we like to eat
but how is it the questions of
food take on great importance?
How is it that culturally
and individually a man
about to face the firing
squad finds solace and meaning
in remembering the great meals he
shared and also finds a possibility
of continuing by passing
on that menu?
It isn't simply or even primarily
I knew about gustatory pleasure.
It isn't just about the
pleasure of filling your belly
or delighting your tongue,
no something much more
was going on there.
It was something about the
continuity of civilization
and in particular about the
continuity of French civilization
but also something about the hearth
and the fundamental
experience we all share.
My wife, Martha, said just the
other day [inaudible] of sitting
down she said dinner
makes sense of the day.
Dinner makes sense of the day.
I think that that's profoundly true.
I was once, and I tell
the story in the book,
I was once interviewing the great
British chef Fergus Henderson.
Does anyone know his wonderful
book, The Whole Beast?
Fergus' theory of, is a carnivore
and he has a wonderful restaurant
in London called St. John, but
it's a form of carnivorism that is
so extreme that it really
resembles a kind of vegetarianism
because what Fergus believes is that
if you're going to eat any piece
of a slaughtered beast
you are responsible
for eating the entire thing.
If you're going to eat
what he calls the fillet,
you have to eat the kidneys
and the brains and the lungs
and the rest of the pig as well.
That the ethical obligation
of the carnivore is to eat
and enjoy the whole beast not
just select pieces of it chosen
by squeamish and fastidious
consumers.
Deeply believes that.
It's a strange belief and a strange
restaurant and they serve squirrels
on leaves and many other
things, but it's delicious
and as I say it's ethically
enormously responsible.
I was talking to Fergus once in
this interview, and he said to me
with a kind of look of
wide-eyed indignation
that you only sometimes encounter in
life and almost always among people
who have passion and
powerful, ethical convictions,
he said to me you know I never
understand when I'm talking
to a young couple and they
say we're getting married
and we've bought a bed and
a sofa and I want to say
to them what are you
doing with a bed?
What possible use is a sofa?
How can you buy a television?
Don't you know the
table comes first?
And I knew immediately what he
meant, and I knew immediately
that that would be the title of this
book about Jacques-Decour's question
about why questions of food
take on great importance.
He meant that the table comes first
because it's the one plausible raft
we can take down the river of life
and return to and be restored by
evening after evening and week
after week and year after year.
So that was the subject that I
wanted to take for this book.
I often say to my writing
students, I say often say
but the one time I was ever
asked to write, to teach writing,
that any interesting essay has
one object and another subject.
Am I going too fast here?
Is this okay?
Good. Thank you.
A good essay always has
an ostensible object
and an actual subject.
So if I'm writing about baking
bread, I'm really writing
about my relationship
with my mother.
Or if I'm writing about learning
to drive, I'm actually writing
about my relationship
with my father and so on.
We all do that and that's what
we all like in a good essay.
So this book as a whole as a
collection of essays was going
to have as its ostensible
object, food,
but as its actual subject
the persistence
of civilization in
its microcosmic form.
The persistence of shared identity,
the possibility of passing on not
as we experience it in the great
halls of literature and history,
but as we experience it in the
daily minutiae of the dining table,
and I wanted to see how those two
things could touch each other,
all the moments when the big,
official history of wars and battles
and revolutions touched
the table and all the times
when the table touched the big
history of wars and revolutions.
And that's the subject I took
for myself and tried to explore
and I tried to explore it
in a lot of different ways.
I looked, for instance, in one
of the first chapters I looked
at the invention of the
restaurant because I thought
that was a particularly interesting
subject exactly because we think
of the restaurant as being perpetual
and eternal thing who would have
to invent a restaurant to go eat in?
It's like inventing a
bed to make love in.
It's sort of self-evident the form
is determined by the appetite,
but that turns out to
be not true at all.
If you actually look at the
history of the restaurant
and how it came about, the
restaurant as we know it
that is a place where you go and
you're given a menu and a variety
of choices where the kitchen is
usually hidden, a place that you use
as a kind of arena of courtship
or of intimate business.
In France, that has a very
specific starting date
in the 1780s just before the French
Revolution in a specific location,
around the Palais-Royale [phonetic].
I don't know if any of you
have spent time in Paris,
but you know that's an
extraordinarily beautiful formal
garden with an arcade
and buildings around it.
The French Cultural Ministry
is there but in its day
in the 18th Century
it was very close
to being essentially the
first mall, the first place
where you had arcaded shops
including what were the first
restaurateurs, the first places that
sold a kind of restorative bouillon
in highly healthy environment.
That was the way that the first
restaurateurs sold their place not
that this is a place
to come for courtship
but this is a place to
come for your health.
This is exactly the way they tell
gym memberships today, right?
It's not about who you'll meet it's
about what you'll do for the good
of your body, it's a very basic kind
of con game that the world plays
and that's how the restaurant began.
[Laughter] So you have something
with a very specific starting
point and, yes, indeed,
it goes without saying that there
are many alternative traditions
that resemble them [inaudible]
Asia and so on, but the restaurant
as well know it, the
institution as we know it,
begins at a particular place and it
involves this is exactly the moment
when history touches the table,
it involves a whole new berth
of culture, of pleasure
and conversation.
Some of you if you've studied
history and philosophy know
that the great German
philosopher, Jurgen Habermas,
his very famous theory
of the French Revolution
where he says it was
really made in the cafes,
it was made by conversation
in the cafes.
That's the foundation of it.
People began exchanging
ideas in semi-private spaces
and then they begin to become
dubious, doubtful, of authority.
They have smaller cells,
smaller realms of verbal
and political exchange and
that becomes kind of like
with an atomic bond that's the fuse
that sets off the big
bomb of social revolution.
Well, in the same way, the
restaurant played a similar kind
of role as part of this new
civilization of semi-private spaces
where you could go
and find an identity
that wasn't meekly assigned
only by your birth role,
by the social status
you inherited at birth.
So it's an example early in the book
of how history touches the table
and the table touches history,
but I was also interested
by the other questions kind
of trying to test out the ways
and the theories by which we live.
So let me read you one more thing
and then I'll open it
up to conversation.
One of the things that I got
interested in as a question
of moral taste of a place where
mouth taste touches moral taste,
is the whole question
of the localvoire,
the whole question of local eating.
I'm sure any of you who are
interested in food are interested
in ethics know that that's one
of the most potent movements
that's afoot in the food world.
The idea that we should eat
in a relatively narrow local food
shed thereby sparing the planet the
pollution that comes with shipping
food over great distances but also
on the grounds that it
creates a much more healthy
and sustainable agricultural
environment nearby.
So, being a New Yorker I had the
idea of seeing if our family,
the four of us, could live for a
week only on things that were grown
and raised in the boroughs
of New York City.
Only things that came
from New York City.
I'll read you a little
bit of that piece.
It's called Near or Far.
Twelve-thirty on a beautiful summer
day and the Chicken Committee
of the City Chicken Project is
meeting at the Garden of Happiness
in the Crotona neighborhood
of the Bronx.
The Chicken Committee is
devoted to the proliferation
of egg laying chickens in the outer
boroughs of New York giving hens
to people and having them raise the
birds in community gardens and eat
and even sell the eggs passing
on the gift as this is called
in the project and thereby
gain experience of chickens,
eggs and community or fowl,
food and fellowship as one
of the more literative
minded organizers has said.
It is the pet program of Just
Food, a small organization
that is administered by a startling
young looking woman named Jackie
Berger, who is silently
monitoring the proceedings.
The Garden of Happiness is
a sunny community garden
with vegetable plots, a
chicken co-op, a chicken coop.
It's funny I read it as a New
Yorker as a chicken co-op.
[Laughter] A chicken coop,
a corrugated tin shed
and a few chairs beneath
a [inaudible]
where the Chicken Committee
is meeting.
The Chicken Committee is a lot
more committee than chicken.
Its deliberations filled
with references
to existing chicken situations and
pursuits of newer egg opportunities
and the slightly skeptical
neighborhood of people have
to be gently won over by the
carefully beaming professionals.
It's like a long questionnaire,
you know,
one of the neighborhood people says
about a form about to be handed
out to potential chicken carers.
Well, don't you think that
someone who isn't prepared to fill
out a few questions is it don't you
have to question their commitment
to caring for a chicken
over the winter?
Yeah, I guess so, but it's a long
thing all of these questions.
The Garden of Happiness has
the semi-magical ability common
to any place in the city with trees
and plants and animals just a seed
from the environment and become
what most of the world is most
of the time a bit out in
the country somewhere.
A hen in the coop starts clucking.
A scruffy Pit Bull
in the neighboring yard
begins to growl and then bark.
Undiscouraged the hen goes on
clucking and a second hen joins her.
I have come to the Garden
of Happiness not only
to see a New York City Chicken
Committee in operation but also
to get myself a chicken to roast.
This was why a few
moments later I was trying
to arrange privately
for a hit on a fowl.
Getting a chicken that has
been raised and slaughtered
in New York City is harder
than it might seem with laws
and bylaws entangling
the transaction.
I wanted to eat a chicken that had
been raised in the city and insiders
who cannot be named said that
although the city chickens
in the Bronx are raised
strictly for their eggs,
in private a poultry whacking
could be arranged for a price.
I had been set up with a chicken
keeper who I'll call Freddy.
[Laughter] Looks like you got,
you know, chickens, I said,
sidling up to him in what I imagine
to be the best Washington
Square marijuana buying manner
as we stared at the coop.
Yeah. Long pause.
Euphemism I saw would get you only
so far in the poultry whacking game.
I was wondering if maybe on Friday
or Saturday you could get me
a chicken I said, you know,
the kind that people can eat.
I tried to give the words a
Soprano's like significance.
Yeah. I understand, Freddy
said, not making eye contact.
Another long silence.
So, I took a deep breath.
So, uhm, you think
there will be a chicken?
After another pause he
said with exactly the kind
of ominous serenity you
want in a hit man, why not?
[Laughter] Come on Saturday.
You be there, there
will be a chicken.
I felt unreasonably
pleased with myself.
The chicken was going to be hit
and I would pay for the action.
I went back a week later.
I had gone all over the
city of New York trying
to find the few working farms
and there are a few, a couple,
that were still there, and I was
told at one point, for instance,
that they do, there's a farm
on Staten Island they do all
of the fertilizing with
elephant dung from the Bronx Zoo
and that you can taste the
tang of the elephant dung
in the eggplants that they raise.
I was delighted in telling my
children this though I suspected it
is a urban legend that
they like to tell people
like us who are shopping.
With all of the good farm
vegetables on hand I decided
to make Saturday dinner
the centerpiece
of our local eating moment featuring
one blow out meal of good things
from around the boroughs, but
I was more than determined
than ever to collect that chicken.
I pulled up at the meeting
spot that Saturday I had chosen
with Freddy near the
coop and there he was.
So, you go the chicken I said
looking at the sky in my sunglasses?
Yeah, I got you the chicken.
This one he said and pointed down
at one of the handsome whites.
The chickens pecked and clucked.
Oh, I said, well, I was
hoping you would, you know,
make it ready for us to eat.
For the first time in our
exchanges Freddy turned towards me.
You want me to kill it he said?
[Laughter] I don't know,
I can't kill my chickens.
I raise them, I love them.
I thought you wanted it, you
said you wanted a chicken.
We looked at each other head on.
It's like, that's like
all bloody and all.
I don't do that he said with
apology and annoyance mixed.
Then a little anger crept in.
I thought you wanted a
chicken to raise not to kill.
I concluded the piece after finally
we assembled our meal together
and this is a case where,
again, the table touches I think
on the biggest questions we ask
ourselves that the arguments
for localism may not be as strong
as we think they are when we think
about sustainability and the planet
there's a good counter argument you
can make that if it's much easier
to raise lambs say in New Zealand
that ultimately you're saving
more carbon energy, you're greener
if you raise your lamb in New
Zealand and ship it to New York
than if you try to raise it
in the more hospitable
ground of Upstate New York.
And I ended by saying the best
argument for eating the local,
the local tomatoes instead
of the African green beans is
that they really do taste better.
We hear a lot these days about
the fact value distinction.
The famous philosophical idea
that distinguishes what is
from what ought to be and insist
that no fact no matter how
strong can determine our values,
but we should perhaps
pay as much attention
to what we might call the
act value distinction.
The distinction that makes us see
that it is not necessary for a thing
to make something else good happen
in order to be good in itself.
What if after all our beliefs
about sustainability in the planet
and food turned out to be false or
redundant or a very minor value?
Would we then give up
going to farmers markets
and stewing organic lamb and
all go out together to Wendy's?
I think it would still
be worth cooking slowly
and shopping locally using Fergus
Henderson's whole beast not
because these are acts that will
demonstrably do something good
but because we believe these
things are good in themselves.
We like them now.
They don't ward off our later ills
they provide our present pleasures.
It's good for you because
it tastes good though far
from perfect advice is
generally stronger wisdom
than its opposite it ought to taste
good because it's good for you.
Stronger because it
appeals to an increasing joy
because it addresses the fact of
appetite, stronger because it speaks
to first principles of pleasure.
The fragility of life means that
our goal can never be to extend it
but to enjoy it for
the simple reason
that we can't really extend it
and we know right now
if we're enjoying it.
The fiercest arguments about ways
of eating tend to be the hardest
to settle while the most frivolous
ones are the most definitive.
You should drink wine, eat
chocolate, have dessert,
fill your plate because
they fit your hunger
and you should eat locally because
it connects you to your landscape,
city breed or countrified.
We can at least be definitive about
that for the life lived with a face
on our food is a richer one
than a life lived without it.
We can have our cake and eat it
too if you are willing to see
that the only point of
having cake is to eat it.
We can never know for sure what is
cause and what is just correlation,
what's merely the happenstance
of simultaneous acts
and what is the true order
of virtuous succession.
Perhaps red wine makes
our hearts healthier.
Perhaps it is only
that wealthier people
with already healthy hearts are the
kinds who choose to drink red wine.
We don't or rarely know for
certain what makes things happen.
We do know what things are like when
we eat or touch or watch them now.
The best argument against
violent video games isn't
that it makes kids
violent later it's
that it shows kids violence now.
It isn't what it does,
it's what it is.
We will never know for
certain what food will do.
We do know what dinner
is and that's enough.
Thank you so much and
I would love to --
[ Applause ]
-- take some questions if I may?
>> Yes, thank you for a
very dynamic presentation.
And I [inaudible] listening
to all your books
and I know you've done some audio
book work for your other writing.
I was just wondering if you could
talk about that and whether you plan
to do the same with
your food writing?
>> Adam Gopnik: Thank you.
Audio books I love to do.
I did an, I believe I did
the audio book of this one.
I do audio books.
I've done audio books of all
of my books because I'm a ham
and I like to show off
and I like to do them.
They're a very strange experience.
I don't know this is why we
come to literary festivals
where authors can tell
you secrets like these.
They lock you in a little isolation
booth and you're not allowed
to eat anything while
you're recording the book
because any sound, lip sounds
and the gastric rumblings
from your stomach will appear
on the final take because you're
in a very tight little space.
So, it takes 4 or 5 days
to record a book and all
of that time you're not
eating anything all day long.
It's a kind of monastic discipline
that you have to submit to.
And I like to think that I've
gotten better at reading my books
in the 15 years or so that I've
been doing my own audio books.
I always assume, it take it as a
compliment that they always ask me
to do it, but now that I
think about it as I look
at you I think you know just be they
don't want to pay anybody to do them
and they know I come cheap.
But when I first started doing
them I would read too quickly
as you probably hear.
I speak quickly and I was
reading much too quickly.
So the producer would say
please speak more slowly.
And then I slowed down
my voice until I sounded
like a joke Rabbi on television.
[Laughter] And then
they said, no, speed up,
speak a little more quickly.
So, if you listen to my audio books,
you'll hear me it's like somebody
who is, you know, on
an amphetamine bender
because at first I'm talking
very, very, very quickly
and then the producer says
no, no, slow down a bit
and then I read very, very
slowly for another chapter
and then I forget and the
next chapter goes very,
very quickly again and then
the producer intervenes.
So all of my audio books
have two distinct speeds,
which you will notice if you listen
to them, but I love doing them
and it delights me when people
seem to enjoy listening to them.
One of the things you know New York
City is a very weird place and one
of the ways it's really
weird is that our,
kind of our habits are very
different from the habits
of the rest of the country and one
of the things we don't do a lot
in New York is commute
in cars, right?
So I'm always surprised when I'm out
in what I think will soon be obliged
by legal compulsion to
call the Real American.
>> Oh, oh, oh.
>> Adam Gopnik: Exactly.
When I'm out elsewhere I'm always
astounded by the number of people
who say, no, no, I've
read your books.
Well, I haven't really read
them but I've listened to them
when I'm driving to work.
So, that's a cool part of it.
Sometimes a couple of
people have told me
that they jog while
listening to my books,
but I think that would be a
recipe for disaster if they do it.
But thank you for that question.
Gentleman here?
>> Yeah. My wife and I have
been committed vegetarians
for about 40 years.
>> Adam Gopnik: Forty-years?
>> Forty years, at
least 40 years, yeah.
>> Adam Gopnik: Wow.
You look so young.
You're like an advertisement --
>> -- since about 15 or so.
Our first date we, first
dinner date, we actually went
to a vegetarian Indian
restaurant in the East Village.
We started talking about it I said I
was a vegetarian because I believed
in sustainability and, you
know, beef destroys the earth.
And she said, well,
you know I like animals
and you should treat animals kindly.
By the end of the night we
started yelling at each other.
The union of this odd
couple has been
that we've got now
a vegan 16 year old.
>> Adam Gopnik: Oh, now, really.
>> She said my damn
parents, they don't give,
they don't care at all about the --
>> Adam Gopnik: -- that's right.
>> But the, I mean the
root of all of this is
that food has been central to
our family for years and years
and the fast food culture that
we have developed, you know,
particularly in the US I think
is destroying culture, history,
community, family, and I know you
write a little bit about this,
you know, sometimes tongue
in cheek, but can you talk
about what your food culture
means and how we can move away
from the fast food put it on the,
not even put it on the table,
eat it in the car and what that
means for how we're organized
as a society, how we
relate to each other,
the existence of families
of these [inaudible].
>> Adam Gopnik: Sure.
I'll be delighted to.
First of all I should say that my
family, the four of us, we go in
and out of spasmodic vegetarianism,
you know, everybody kind of looks
and said, you know, we really
shouldn't for the reasons your wife
for ethical reasons we should
become ethical vegetarians and one
of other the kids bangs
their, his or her first,
and says I'm an ethical
vegetarian now.
And then it fades after about
two weeks and they go back
and I realize it's sort
of the equivalent for sort
of Manhattan metropolitan
people of finding Jesus
and then losing Jesus
again, you know?
You find him and then you
lose him and then you go back
and you find him again,
and we treat vegetarianism
in that same hyper
spiritualized way.
The whole question I have
complicated feelings.
One of my favorite French saying is
that grown up people should be able
to count to two meaning that you
rarely resolve a moral question
with one category or
one commandment.
It usually takes some development.
I [inaudible] evangelical in this
book and in all of my writing
and in my own personal
practice about the importance
of the local market, the
green market, farmers,
dinner served at a
table cooked by a parent
or by a kid I deeply
believe in those things.
I believe that that really
is the sustainability
of civilization depends
on dinner, it much begins
at dinner as Lord Byron said.
Much depends on dinner
I beg your pardon,
and I believe those things are vital
and central and it's hard for me
to conceptualize a rich,
not only rich family life
but a rich civilization that
doesn't have the consistent
and traditional rituals
of food at its core.
At the same time that
counting to two, right,
at the same time I
would be a terrible snob
and horribly unrealistic if I didn't
recognize that the fast food culture
that you have described
has grown up not simply
as a shoddy moral preference
but in response
to the huge unimaginable pressures
of daily life in a
capitalist society.
So I would never want to be
morally punitive about people
who have a different set
of rituals than I do.
And I think that's one of the tricks
in a pluralist country is you have
to be evangelical about your
values without being moralistic
about their absence in other people.
That's a complicated two step,
but I think it's an important one.
[ Applause ]
Broadly applicable I would say.
So, I try and keep both
things I mind as I do.
I think that it's remarkable when
you look around to see the degree
to which, you know, that's the
salad and McDonald's, right?
To see the degree to which the
values of that were regarded
as extremely [inaudible]
elitists used that horrible word.
Thirty years ago I think
of my friend, Alice Waters,
about whom I have a chapter
the originator of Chez Panisse
in Berkeley and one of the first
people to bring these values
in a very aggressive way to America.
And she, actually when I
was with her in France once
and I said has your daughter
ever been to McDonald's?
And what would you say if she asked?
She said, oh, I would simply say I
would prefer not to become involved
in that kind of activity.
[Laughter] Which I
thought was like going
to a brothel, you know,
or something.
Values that were elitist when Alice
first spouts them 50 years ago,
40 years ago, are now commonplace
and you see them everywhere.
You see them even in, you know, Pret
A Monjay [phonetic], or some places
like that, fast food places
that have those values.
So I think that we should
never apologize for believing
in those things, but we should
never enforce them in any way
and we should always have a
little bit of modesty in our minds
because we know that whatever
the good food rules are
of our time will look ridiculous
50 years hence and we know
that because the good rules
of 50 years past look
ridiculous to us in lots of ways.
What counted as good food
then now looks more dubious.
So I try to keep both
things in mind.
In fact at one point in this book, I
explain and you don't get many books
like this, that I give you the
secret of life, the secret of life,
and it's right in the middle
of the third chapter actually.
I shouldn't tell you, you'd have
to buy it and you'll get the secret
of life, but basically it makes
sense same point in a different way
that the secret of life is having
enough passion about your values
to live them fully and enough
irony about your values
to view them skeptically.
I'll take one last question
and then I have to go.
>> Do you ever go to
dinner with Calvin Trillin
and exchange food philosophies?
>> Adam Gopnik: I wouldn't want
to go to dinner with Trillin
because he would take
all the food, you know.
He's more of a fresser [phonetic]
than a philosopher, Trillin,
but it's nice that you ask that as
we finish up because I have been
to dinner with Trillin
from time to time.
We always seem to end up at
occasions like this and people say,
oh, they both are big eaters and
Jewish so we'll put them together
at a thing, but Trillin's
food writing, Alice Let's Eat,
American Fry, those wonderful
books, totally opened
up for me the possibility
that writing
about food can not only be funny
as I hope mine is sometimes,
but could also be a window
onto domestic delights.
There could be a way of finding
the whole little play of what we do
and as a consequence the first
thing you will read in this book,
The Table Comes First, is the
dedication page for Martha,
Luke and Olivia, my family, who
sit in chair at the nightly table
and for Calvin Trillin,
who set the standard.
So, thanks so much.
Thank you so much for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.